AYSYLU GREENBERG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Aysylu Greenberg, and I'm
here at Kubecon San Diego 2019.
I'm a senior software
engineer at Google.
And today, I gave a talk
on Binary Authorization
in Kubernetes.
It was a joint talk
with Liron Levin,
who is one of the biggest
contributors to both Grafeas
and Kritis projects.
And we discussed how
Grafeas and Kritis
can help you secure your
software supply chain.
If you are not familiar with the
term "software supply chain,"
it's basically
all the steps that
take you through committing
the code to the code base,
and then building it and testing
it using continuous integration
pipelines, and then deploying
it to Kubernetes using
continuous delivery pipeline.
And in this talk,
we also discussed
how to populate the
data into Grafeas--
Liron showed a nice demo of the
Twistlock populating the data--
and then deploying
that to Kubernetes
and using Kritis to actually
gain the deployment, depending
on whether you found critical
vulnerabilities or not.
So if you came to the
talk, thank you very much.
If you haven't seen
it yet, I highly
recommend you check it
out when it's online.
And please come by the Google
booth at Kubecon San Diego.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]